en este momento Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva está en una situación muy
diferente al país ha cambiado están en
un entorno muy distinto al que había
hace 20 años cómo va a ser él para
reconciliar estos dos escenarios tan
diferentes y volver a Pues a retomar esa
senda de crecimiento en Brasil y sacar a
tanta gente de la pobreza
Bueno buenas tardes En primer lugar es
un placer estar acá en relación a tu
pregunta bueno hemos visto un Lula
sensiblemente conmovido un Lula muy
humano en este segundo discurso
expresando bueno todo lo que representa
su llegada su retorno al poder no por la
tercera vez creo que vale destacar aquí
varios puntos no en primer lugar las
características personales células Silva
como una persona dotada de una gran
capacidad de negociación de conciliación
ha sido dos veces presidente tiene una
experiencia extraordinaria a nivel
político y también ha remarcado más
veces que su regreso no
únicamente El Triunfo de la Democracia
que ya de por sí es un grandísimo logro
sino también la vuelta de la política no
la vuelta de la política como el arte de
lo posible la vuelta de la política como
negociación la vuelta de la política
contra con pragmatismo pero sin dejar de
lado el idealismo no Lula ha dejado muy
claro esto que bueno viene a gobernar
para los 215 millones de brasileños
viene a ser un gobierno compuesto por
todos y para todos viene a responder a
las necesidades que el país se enfrenta
y quiere responder a los digamos a las
necesidades y justamente garantizar los
derechos de la mayoría de brasileños sí
esto por supuesto no se da en un
escenario fácil ni a nivel doméstico ni
a nivel internacional tenemos un país
que como bien ha destacado nula es un
país marcado por gobiernos recientes
especialmente el gobierno de Jairo
bolsonaro por gobiernos de destrucción
no a nivel institucional
los gobiernos que han amenazado ya el
gobierno del expresidente temer y sobre
todo el gobierno bolsonero abiertamente
a la democracia pero que además dejaron
un legado terrible a nivel económico de
desmonte institucional y entonces no
será para nada fácil en algunos casos se
tratará de Volver a empezar sin embargo
es necesario también decir que bueno
pues tenemos a este Lula con mucha
experiencia Estela con una amplia
capacidad de negociación tenemos no solo
alumnas sino Un gobierno de coalición un
gobierno que representa un frente amplio
y que va a negociar con todos y con
todos a nivel internacional viene este
nuevo gobierno para romper justamente
con el aislamiento que caracterizó la
política exterior de bolsonaro y en ese
sentido si bien tu la destacó en el
discurso anterior y en este la retomada
la integración regional como una
prioridad Sí también Es verdad que bueno
se va a trabajar en varios frentes no
con los con china en particular con
Europa con todo es un gobierno que viene
para trabajar con todos es un gobierno
que le va a apostar muchísimo a la
cooperación internacional y que tiene
como uno de sus ejes prioritarios el
trabajo contra bueno la emergencia
ambiental y climática que estamos
enfrentando no Entonces es también Un
gobierno que tiene ante sí varias
oportunidades en un contexto en el que
existe conciencia ambiental y voluntad
de trabajar internacionalmente por esto
bueno Brasil también tiene allí varias
oportunidades con lo cual respondiendo a
tu pregunta no será nada fácil pero creo
que hay
algunos factores que nos permiten bueno
avisorar la posibilidad de que cumpla
buena parte de sus promesas María para
nadie es un secreto que en Brasil va a
haber un cambio sin duda alguna porque
veníamos de un presidente de extrema
derecha ahora el país Mira hacia el
progresismo Cuáles son esos primeros
cambios que van a comenzar a ver los
brasileños a partir de hoy que ya toma
posesión un nuevo gobierno con una
tendencia política totalmente disti a la
de su antecesor
Sí bueno son varios creo que ya hemos
empezado desde el inicio Lula hay bueno
varias varios términos que pueden
resumir digamos su regreso al poder no
pero tres de ellos han sido remarcados
en su discurso unificación pacificación
y reconstrucción del país sí llegó a
decir que no viene con revanchas si
viene a gobernar para todas y todos
Entonces el el poner esto no el utilizar
este tipo de discursos un discurso que
habla de Esperanza un discurso que habla
de la necesidad de superar el odio que
habla de la necesidad de pensar
colectivamente en el país en el hipo
brasileño Ya de por sí es un cambio
importantísimo respecto al discurso de
odio que por ejemplo marcó el gobierno
de Jairo Más allá de esto bueno tenemos
una serie de reformas que se han dado el
anuncio de los 37 ministerios con una
presencia histórica de mujeres 30% en
este sentido Bueno hoy ahí hay un
déficit en relación a la paridad pero es
un cambio muy importante hay una
cantidad importantísima de mujeres en el
Ministerio se retoma el Ministerio de la
mujer hay también cinco representantes
del pueblo afrodescendiente de Brasil sí
que es la mayoría de la población
brasileña tenemos un ministerio que va a
combatir las desigualdades raciales la
discriminación racial esto es un cambio
fundamental para un país que bueno aún
hoy enfrenta distintos problemas en
relación a la discriminación racial y la
desigualdades por estas razones Tenemos
también el primer ministerio dedicado
exclusivamente a los pueblos indígenas y
que va a estar presidido por Sonia
guayara que es una importante líder
indígena del país entonces bueno este
anuncio de una reforma que piensa no de
una de un equipo ministerial y de un
país de un proyecto de un país que está
pensando en reunificar en pacificar y
sobre todo en reconstruir para todos y
todos Ya de por sí es un gran cambio de
aquí a bueno en adelante Se esperan una
serie de otras reformas que permitan
implementar esto pero sin duda estamos
ya ante un cambio muy significativo que
bueno retoma esta idea de que es posible
reconstruir Brasil que hay que volver a
tener esperanza se ASUME un tono
optimista una voluntad de que Brasil se
convierta de hecho en un protagonista
también de las relaciones
internacionales sobre todo a partir de
esto que algunos y algunas autoras
denominan como progresismo ambiental
nuestra idea de unir las preocupaciones
por cuestiones de naturaleza social no
la lucha contra la desigualdades y lo ha
dejado muy claro que va a enfrentar
todas las desigualdades Sí pero en este
marco ocupa especial importancia a la
cuestión ambiental entonces bueno Esto
también es un cambio muy importante
frente a un gobierno como el de Jair
bolsonaro que se caracterizó por la
destrucción y el desmonte de la
institucionalidad de lucha contra los
problemas ambientales que fue bueno
gobierno caracterizado por el récord de
deforestación y de destrucción ambiental
no Entonces los cambios son muchos
volvemos en Brasil a tener un gobierno
con un programa que pone nuevamente en
el centro la política Sí y la democracia
por supuesto